I like all these people too talking
about how awful this country is right
now and how [__] up it is and all that
type of [__] it's just like I gotta be
upset about what Bud Light puts on the
side of a [__] beer can which by the
way
was that one of the dumbest [__]
moves they're a corporation they want to
make money how much do they not know
their own audience I've never seen
anybody with even remote
intellect or empathy standing there with
a Bud Light did you see what they did
when he wrote the apology the head of
Anheuser-Busch he had to just write
something because they lost five billion
dollars and everybody started getting
upset and then their next commercial
they brought the Clydesdale back no they
didn't oh dude they went old school dude
[__] breath coming out of the horse's
thing the [__] Clydesdale that was
the only worst move than doing what they
did you come back and apologize you try
to over correct with that yeah
only straight guys to like busty Green
Card beer
but like we're straight again